[Music]
one minute and two seconds of logos over
two minutes of credits on top of clouds
that do nothing for nobody something
does happen in this movie called the
happening right Jesus Christ the score
is so much better than the movie in
which it's situated that I'm gonna throw
an extra five sends it I'm so sorry you
have to see this mr. Newton Howard in
case you confused it with Central Park
Oklahoma City I forgot where you're at
the place where the killer's meet to
decide what to do with the cripples girl
even for an M night Shyamalan movie
thing what the appropriate question is
is this what she's actually looking at
because I can't see a goddamn thing and
I'm guessing she can't see whatever
she's looking at from this distance
either
because there's nothing King there you
know back in 2008 those Improv
Everywhere assholes would sometimes go
way too far
of course there's one asshole in this
entire Park that's temporarily immune to
the evil Windy voodoo happening so we
can have some sort of explicit narrative
of what's happening rather than just
watching it happening happening I can't
wait till they get to Nebraska and they
tell us it's twenty five thousand nine
hundred twenty eight blocks from Central
Park New York City well I saw your thing
and it said WY the big guy says no man
mine says welcome to Jamaica have a nice
day that's a long dick joke right there
she says give him some of them give the
injured person some room cliche I mean
seriously these guys are standing well
away from the body also the beginning of
this movie is really just an excuse for
M night to show off how many different
ways people can die which was already
done much more effectively 15 years
before in Groundhog Day look I don't
know if you guys have heard about this
article New York Times about honey bees
vanishing Mark Wahlberg playing anything
with sincerity always comes off like a
guy really wants to try this acting
thing like everything sincere is said
with an urgency it doesn't quite desert
hey guys did you hear the Sun is going
to supernova in the future maybe it's
time we started planning for Earth's
evacuation because we're not gonna make
it when that happens
also movie just assumes that these high
schoolers would be carefully poring over
the science section of the New York
Times and some of the might sure but
Dignam sounds like he expects them to
also in case you confused it for
Philadelphia High School Pittsburgh is
scary huh
this is the question that m-might
constantly ask the entire crew with this
movie during filming should be more
interesting science Jake you know why
because
your face is perfect King priceless an
act of nature and we'll never fully
understand it nice answer Jake he's
right dude this is the equivalent of
answering because when a teacher asks
why or saying because language is like
life man science will come up with some
reason to put in the books
I mean we will fail to acknowledge that
there are forces at work beyond our
understanding
weirdly enough the text for this class
was edited by Mike Huckabee I'd like to
think of this movie as a sequel to Dead
Poets Society that went terribly
terribly wrong also
so is this blatant insubordination to
the vice-principal is supposed to endear
Elliot to his students like I can't
figure out how you're excellent this
assholes supposed to be it's basically
Jason sportsman's character and yo teach
this classroom has two light switches
not terribly far apart from each other
and with only one entrance exit I know
why the music department couldn't get
their funding now why did the vice
principal drag mark Walberg out of his
class personally when it looks like
these teachers were told via a normal
communication device the intercom or did
the vice-principal direct each one of
these teachers out individually and
finally got to him just now there
appears to be an event happening roll
credits also let it never be said that
the principal of the school was hired
based on his communication skills
Central Park was just hit by what seems
to be a terrorist attack
Central Park that's kind of odd it
really really isn't what makes Central
Park honor than any other place where
this could happen that's happening in
New York we saw the students looking at
their phones so they know what's going
down but sure let's focus more on the
students big grudging respect for their
weirdly swoll teacher hey guys no I'd
like to imagine that the script told
Elliot to say hey guys and then when
Mark Wahlberg turned the page he found
the script link and who figured he had
to literally say what was on the page I
told her the probability of something
happening in Philadelphia is very low
especially an NBA championship now let
me think about that okay is there a
reason that the camera is right in there
when it cuts to Elliot she's acting I
just don't worry about it I know you're
used to that kind of behavior by hanging
out with me anyway I'm gonna tell you
something
you should never tell your best friend
why is everybody saying that nobody has
said that at all in this movie to anyone
for any reason until now I walk into a
room by mistake and she was crying
that's not who she is she's never want
to jump in when you need him man okay a
couple things here first Julian walked
into the waiting room by accident second
just from this brief encounter he knows
for sure that Alma and Elliot aren't
gonna work third he's never told them
about this and waits until there's a
potential disaster and they're
surrounded by high school kids to drop
this truth bomb cheese and crackers
that's can we unpack what's happening
here oh my gets a call from her
potential side piece but rather than
decline the call since she knows
Elliot's almost home she lets that ring
the whole way
then when Elliot does get home she
doesn't immediately erase the call I
know this is the late-2000s but besides
maybe Tiger Woods people knew how to
properly cellphone why does the World
News Network constantly show the
temperature for only Philadelphia this
new neurotoxin is basically flipping the
preservation switch and I'm reporting
from outside the building with no
personal protection despite the toxin
being clearly airborne in this city also
Matt there's never been a more
convenient time for Elliot to walk in on
some perfect exposition just when you
thought there couldn't be any more
beautiful that could be invented hey we
still haven't even gotten to the last
airbender and after earth I don't know
if there was technically a feature where
the buzzer on a flip phone would ring
constantly but I choose to believe that
all my hackers and turned it into a sex
toy since the last time it rang
autopsies on the first victims confirm
that toxin is a natural compound so
there's the theory that this movie is
about mass paranoia and in fact nothing
is happening at all and people are doing
bizarre things because their minds are
playing tricks on them and that all the
goofballs we see is a result of this
mental play but when the movie puts in
segments like this or a sane newscasters
reporting news from scientists starts to
break those walls down plus it's somehow
only affects people in the Northeast and
in the day of the internet and cable
news this masked paranoia would have hit
way more areas of the country how are
you
you good the hell's the deal between
these two was there more to that waiting
room encounter than we knew about could
he ultimately be the Joey that keeps
calling her goddamn phone movie asks way
too many unanswerable questions I don't
get all sensitive just give her a chance
skip and look maybe it's a mass paranoia
metaphor but is this how a mass paranoia
starts with a bunch of people doing the
same thing at the same time
independently of each other
it would make more sense if you had one
person think they see something tell
someone else make that person paranoid
and so on this is not that all so I'm
pretty sure this entire movie is based
on that Radiohead just video only with
attempts at explanations that make the
mystery not fun to watch the hallmark of
this genius neurotoxin is clearly its
flair for dramatic timing the thing this
guy picks up the gun walked several Fifa
killing himself so that the woman on the
sidewalk can see the gun and complete
this one take of man
we ate kara miisu together that is it so
that's what the kids were calling it
back in 2008 I guess it was the Netflix
and chill ten years ago she got on a bus
con New Jersey she's headed to the town
of Princeton awesome
mommy's headed back into the path of the
evil death toxin even if you believe the
attacks on New York and Philly were
specific to those locations why would
you go anywhere near those two areas
much less right in between them I'm
sorry ma'am the correct wording is what
the hell is happening Eliot I'm afraid
I'm gonna have to ask you to exit the
bus train service has been discontinued
this would be the last stop for all
passengers it's hilarious how the train
workers decide to go with the we're
stopping here and you're just gonna have
to deal with it and you for being
curious method instead of just telling
them something about the attacks that
everyone in the world knows about it
would be a satisfactory explanation for
their stop why are you giving me one
useless piece of information at a time
we lost contact like Mark Wahlberg is
the only asshole who's asking these guys
what's going on I remember once at a
movie theater when a crowd of people ran
into the projection booth to yell at a
projectionist when the shawshank
redemption' stop to think all these
people would be calmly talking amongst
themselves during a supposed
terrorist attack stopped in bumm
Pennsylvania while the train workers
were ten feet away is being laughable
I'm not saying anything stuck here but
they just told you they lost contact
with everyone isn't that terrifying but
useful information shouldn't you be on
the cell phone or watching the news or
doing something other than standing out
in the open air right now well oh I got
it man I can't tell you how many times I
heard my high school science teacher
used the word bro in casual conversation
you know that everyone gives off energy
right this guy look at
it was taken an hour ago with the
Philadelphia Zoo yes come look at this
random stranger with a small child in
his custody come hither to view my
natural death porn the event appears to
be limited to the Northeast
which is as we all know the only
location in America with trees and
plants where are we the dead center now
we have a problem on both sides of the
coin either it's mass paranoia which
this entire diner should be suffering
from or it's an actual chemical attack
which this entire diner should be
suffering from considering it's right in
the damn center of the attack whatever
this is it looks like it's not occurring
about ninety miles from here 90 miles
west south north and how do you know and
yet this is good enough for all these
assholes to leave the diner and probably
without leaving it too but they're
reasonably confident this is an outside
killer whether it's natural or not right
so why the all those cars have the
windows rolled down Juliet I swear to
god this entire Elliot tries to hitch a
ride scene was shot without John
Leguizamo while he was on the set of
righteous kill and then they got him for
an hour or so to shoot this like this is
Elliot's best friend they've been
traveling together the whole time and
yet it looked like for a minute there
one or the other was willing to get a
ride without checking the other status I
can't can't get a man on the phone you
know nothing so your plan is to abandon
your child go to a different epicenter
of this attack which is still a pretty
large city I just stand in the middle of
the toxin filled street and yell for her
this is like the worst parts of the
plans in Cloverfield and what about Bob
combined I got her to take my daughter's
hand unless you mean Rose leaving his
daughter in their care takes time to
threaten one of her caregivers
I knew this movie was bad but it's bad
on a micro-level for some reason the
shot of Leguizamo sitting still in the
Jeep is presented to us in slow motion
subtle packing hot dogs for the road you
know hot dogs get a bad rap
I bet this guy's stand-up back hills and
filbert plants react to human stimulus
they they prove that in tests Elliot
a-qing science teacher doesn't believe
this basic tenet of human plant
interaction essentially agreeing with
Alma not only that aren't they running
for their lives while being pursued by a
natural phenomenon that no one
understands is this the time for
Cavalier tomfoolery
[Music]
you mean this is the first time anyone's
seeing the obviously hanging people in
the middle of the road took until you
were right on top of it to see it even
if the girl in the backseat couldn't see
it until now Julian and the driver are
psychopaths who decided not to warn
anyone before they passed it also these
are hilariously complicated methods of
death right why not just wander into the
local river run the truck into a tree
line the workers in front of the truck
and mow them down and then have only one
person hang themselves my point is that
Emma Knight was so enamored with the
fact that he could show us all these
horrific images that he didn't stop to
ask himself if he should close yes that
will keep this soft-top jeep wrangler
air tight just look at me dude why take
the chance of making her look at your
face to calm her down when she might
have seen the pest or spun or spawn or
the fan also I guess because they're
going to New Jersey this is the movies
attempt to stick Brian O'Halloran aka
Dante Hicks into the movie this is a
poor attempt at putting Dante Hicks in
the movie and I think he wasn't even
supposed to be here today Julian at
least for the time being easily survives
this and we hit the highway from there
were 30 miles from the state line what
state line are they looking for the map
on the TV basically covered the entirety
of the eastern seaboard so the only
possible escape would be west but the
next state over would be the Ohio and
that's a long-ass way away have they
really been driving that long but it's
still daylight
you got binoculars in the back from we
knew he's spying on our neighbors from
the Jeep why did the binoculars need an
explanation I mean yeah we might have
seen this guy having convenient
binoculars but that's still what they
kind of are right
wow what a specific place for all these
people to die especially right out in
the middle of nowhere on a country road
this is clearly not the best place to
organize a flash mob she's in crackers
cheese and crackers it's joy no it's not
that Elliott is suspicious right now
this is just his everyday go to confused
face he's onto something
I think Elliott is in the running to be
the least helpful hero in a movie ever
made an award you know I just made up
hearing tonight in my head bimbeau 30 in
the morning just keep watching out the
window with the tree baby someone will
come and get you
tell it Toa not to go near the window at
the tree baby don't go near the window
with the tree why would anyone listen to
this asshole especially someone who has
no clue what he's talking about this is
her daughter right sorry honey I know
you're scared but this dude looks a lot
like that guy from Rockstar so I'm gonna
go ahead and trust his opinion on how
you should proceed in the disaster
scenario okay
she says everyone's dead outside why are
you talking funny what's wrong with you
Stacy to start dying
after she gave important information
other did she live when everyone else
already died this comes from watching
too much Stand and Deliver
I got an easy remedy for that take two
pulp fiction's and an Argo and you're
right as rain
oh really Oh am I supposed to masturbate
to that also if Elliot is increasingly
suspicious of the goddamn wind which
everyone should be at this point why the
fuck is he not in one of the cars right
now with the windows up seriously this
motherfucker straight-up tells Stacy to
stay away from the windows while he's
out in the middle of open air eating
cold hot dogs yeah it's been a rough day
huh hey better check on Joey to see how
he's holding them trees can communicate
with bushes bushes with grass and
everything in between
hmm this didn't seem insane in the
script but when you hear it out loud
push it away for the rest of them saying
the big group like the Prophet says what
I'm wondering is why they're walking at
all I know the town they're going to has
dirt roads but they're still looking
roads right there has to be a reason why
they were shoeing the safety comfort and
shelter of the cars right right hot dog
guy looks to his right and sees the wind
blowing and god damn it is that ever
suspicious normal everyday we win but
the so called plant expert thinks
there's something different about it and
he's right why do some people talk crazy
when they get infected but most of the
others become immobile and do nothing
sure Mark Wahlberg's weirdly serene
level of concern here is a sin but
everyone else just standing around while
gunshots go off nobody fears for their
lives they just know for a fact that
those people got infected and are
killing themselves something in this
field could be releasing the chemical
into the air when there's too many of us
together holy if it weren't for the
politics Elliot's theory would already
be published in Scientific American
Eliot's scientific method wants to stand
in the field while gunshots taking the
lives of his fellow travelers rang out
from this he came up with his
groundbreaking larger group theory in
which plants decide to let small groups
of people live as long as there's a
larger group in virtually the same area
perceived as a bigger threat the
evidence comes from tickling your own
pink let's just stay ahead of the wind
this iconic line is setting up the
greatest chase against the weather scene
since global warming attacked in the day
after tomorrow here I come what's taking
the wind so goddamn long it's wind but
it seriously needs this long to overtake
some slow-moving assholes also not that
it really matters but didn't anyone
think to cover up their noses mouths or
other orifices like we figured out that
it's in the air but isn't that the hard
part the rest of it keeping it out of
our bodies is relatively simple the wind
of course
nothing and they're fine and this is the
dual problem with whatever this movie is
saying is the threat either it's masked
paranoia which these guys should not be
dying from because there is paranoid as
they could be or it's the toxin which
should have spread to them after the
wind tracked them down but they're okay
and this movie continues could this
really be happening
sorry Max Payne but we've already had
our allowable amounts of roll credits
moments and for the repetition I will
have to award you with 12 extra cents my
name is Elliot Moore maybe somewhere in
this movie is a comedy maybe I'm Knights
laughing at us all for taking this movie
seriously it was a ridiculous gamble
that nearly ended his career though
let's think about that for a second the
timing of this movie if they failed
comedy could not have been worse came
after the village and lady in the water
not exactly the time to be making a
movie where Mark Wahlberg talks to
plants yeah it's the plastic part that
makes talking to it insane why is this
happening
leave me kit I was definitely asking
myself the same question in the movie
theater in 2008 around this point the
bees disappearing it's like a pattern
goddamnit this has nothing to do with
bees Elliot you haven't even mentioned
the fucking bees since the beginning of
the movie there's two groups coming
together there's too many of them
together
barely this proves Elliot right but
remember those construction workers they
were around tons of people who were
flinging themselves off the roof and
they didn't get infected
what about Stacie who was on the phone
with her mom and inside a house all
alone she wasn't around a large group of
people
ironically though Stacy's mom was around
a large group of people maybe it's
because she's got it going up she's all
I want and I've waited for so long M
night Shyamalan really wants you to see
what will happen when this tracker
finally runs over this guy it'll take
about seven hours but eventually you'll
see it heroes find a convenient radio
hanging from a fence but static prevents
them from hearing the entire emergency
broadcast cliche also I hasn't been
playing the whole time thousands of
people are dead in a huge swath of the
Northeast but the last time Elliot
turned on the radio a few minutes ago
mind you there was just talk radio about
a nuclear disaster he's sure we should
keep calling why haven't you figured out
that the problem is a large number of
people they're not racing against the
clock so as long as your group is small
you can camp out anywhere as long as you
can find food right are you choking
I feel like this question and Mark
Wahlberg's definite but not definite
reaction to it sums up what it's like to
watch this movie I think I can open this
door wait we're a gang now we're gonna
take whatever you want or you could try
knocking right this is kind of an
apocalyptic scenario but there are no
fucking zombies around to wake up or
anything you're up against plant life I
think a distinct notification that
you're at the front door would be
insufficient one Blackwater keep on
rolling filled it filled it oh so the
only people were supposed to care about
it literally these three I understand
this is standard crisis storytelling and
she had to kill the Rando kids by
homicide pieces there's nothing about
this movie that makes sense or is
enjoyable there are some quiet rumblings
that the government may be involved in
the tragic events playing out in the
Northeast in a better movie with a clear
message the idea of a news program
speculating without evidence of
government involvement in a terrorist
attack while people in Nebraska are in a
garage circle jerking each other with
guns might be meaningful goes a long way
and trying to prove that this movie is
about paranoia but it's pretty clear
that sports at this point there's a
spring house in the back it has a
speaking tube running under the ground
to the main house I would say this is a
bit of Fortune I doing here but this is
foreshadowing so hard it's basically
four clips don't touch things that
aren't yours can't just one person be
fucking normal for one goddamn moment in
this movie I mean Jesus lady you have a
plate of goddamn cookies here on the
dinner table I would assume those
cookies are there for the taking - how
would you know if something were to
happen like a world of Twitter users to
non twitter users at every cocktail
party scared yeah I don't blame you I
mean that shit was in Carrie plan on
murdering me in my sleep
what No is it comedy is it horror you
don't know also well you convinced her
big guy nice work there with the age-old
argumentative trick of immediate and
Confused denial throes I'm off the trail
every time so I guess the kill large
groups of people thing doesn't matter
anymore sure we've been told that
smaller and smaller groups are getting
infected but you still understand why
the plants which are apparently sentient
killers decided to go with an upside
down pyramid scheme for their murders
also they clearly had a chance to Kelly
it up here but decided against it maybe
for sentimental reasons I don't know
sounds like it's good a reason as any
so with mrs. Jones trying to kill
herself for Bob Lee swagger because I
don't remember anyone giving it about
who they took out after they'd been
exposed to the toxic just that they
wanted to off themselves in a
cinematically grandiose wit also this
does not appear to be one of those
brand-new homes that hermetically seals
any truth this door screams draft right
there's even an open keyhole that can't
get in to kill the dad from the lovely
bones it deserves to be defeated what's
going on Ellie it's happening here god I
wish they'd have properly named this
phenomena like I'd be fine with calling
it a Geo storm or a toxin bust or 2,000
or at the carnage the title of this
movie is essentially a version of the
pronoun game remember the first date I
remove all the sins here if Elliott had
taken Alma to go see I Heart Huckabees
then we check the little paper chart and
it turned up but purple meant I was
horny curiously this guy named Joey had
just walked by seconds before I wouldn't
be with you and I'm gonna come be with
you
damn I mean you can't wait like a couple
hours or anything how long have you been
having this conversation like two
minutes
child abuse also you know what this
ending pisses me off to no end this
entire movie Elliott's had three
character traits indecision the
proclivity to break down a problem using
the scientific method and bad acting and
one of those traits is extremely useful
at this time find a scientifically
viable way to get across the field
without being exposed he's the least
useful scientist ever
he's the anti Watney I mean could you
see this asshole surviving more than a
half soul on Mars also even if he wants
to satisfy his end of the world boner
why is Alma not only putting herself at
risk but exposing Jess at least one of
them couldn't stay back at the fucking
shed doc damn this pisses me off to no
end
oh and yet they've survived this I think
the only reason Ellen I came all the way
out here is that from a distance Elliot
really does look like Joseph
gordon-levitt you know the one oh you
meant the happening damn dude you got to
be a little clearer when discussing your
world threatening events you don't want
to be late for the first day schools are
open in movie world couples who took
care of a kid get to automatically adopt
the kid when it's discovered the kid's
parents have died hang on now three
months it's been three months that's it
I know it seems like a lot of time but
these streets are relatively bustling
especially for the morning not only
three months ago almost everyone in the
Northeast died violently you couldn't
really get that cleaned up and the
infrastructure back online in three
months faces of the neurotoxin haven't
found in some plants and trees if this
movie is about paranoia is it saying the
scientists are paranoid too that they
were so-called findings or really
just grasping at straws I don't know I'm
just glad to short I believe he warned
alike like like the first spot of a rash
and thankfully due to this warning the
movie watching public collectively
dumped themselves in calamine lotion and
we haven't had a recurrence in over 10
years
I guess as soon as the threat was over
Alma's mood ring immediately turned to
purple while they were in that field
house did I add an emo video oh now it's
happening in France they call it live mo
that's French for b-movie okay well it
was great to meet you say hi to your
mother for me okay hey guys I don't have
any reason right now could be plans why
is this happening I don't know for sure
Josh and I believe it's nature may not
be it could be some other explanation I
don't think it's terror sir what no I
wanna be with you and I'm gonna come be
with you
when I tell you to do something I mean
that burn it all mr. Julien Palmas
acting weird just be cool okay what's
going on I say I don't know sometimes I
get the feeling like she's cheating on
me yeah I get that feeling to move you
don't have an opinion
we gotta have an opinion I mean do you
think that God came down from heaven
you're not interested in what happened
to the beasts immediately regret this
decision freaking out you are freaking
out man